so here's my version of the filter
playground method you might have called
your method something different that's
perfectly fine it doesn't matter what
you called it so I return list of type
conference and here i create the initial
query where i'm loading all the
conference's sorted by name and then i
add the filter to filter the on city
equals london and i add the second
filter to filter on topics equals
medical innovations and then i call list
on the query and i return the results
you can also string everything together
into one long statement like this but i
prefer the code to be broken up into
smaller chunks for readability now you
know how to filter queries by property
obviously this function we just rode is
very hard wired and you would more
typically let users pick which values to
filter on and you'll learn how to do
that soon